that'll set it up for alex jackson
struck out as a pinch hitter last night
ground ball to third
hampson goes to second on to first
double play
ladies and gentlemen i might have lied i
said we're going to the bottom of the
second we might not be the marlins are
going to review that call it was a very
close play at first on the back end of
the double play this one clearly and out
with brinson retired but then on the
backside
looks like alex jackson may have beat
that out i believe he did foot is down
i think we have some more baseball here
in the top of the second we do
they have overturned the call so jackson
beats it out goes as a 5-4 fielder's
choice
charlie is three for three by the way
against lizardo
would you even recognize charlie if he
shaved
he's four for four against lizardo he
may have a chance at a double two right
now
and you gotta take advantage
of alfaro who's not gonna move great in
left field
so a leadoff double for blackman
charlie gets beat by this pitch it's up
though two strikes he's not afraid to
just let the ball get deep on him he
uses the opposite field and right out of
the box he's thinking too he knows how
far is the left
alfaro tries to cut this off at a very
steep angle bare hand
and flip it over it made it closer than
i thought
why not go ahead and do it
we get another chance to see his arm
well
he's going to get behind this but this
is a really long throw and
diaz read it beautifully
one nothing colorado great base running
elias diaz connor joe great team at bet
jenny give him a high five he just went
by
well it's really important it's what the
rockies have been doing of late and this
is just a
a young player trying to do too much
hard to take a deep breath of course but
the sentiment is understood this is a
ground ball a diving play by anderson
from his knees and dug out by aguilar
what a play on both ends and he made a
gold glove caliber play to end the
inning well he certainly did and let's
remember there's a runner on second base
that ball gets through we're talking
about another run for the rockies
fantastic job two steps and a dive into
the hole
from his knees strong throw and aguilar
great backhand pick at first
crazy this is live to run trevor has a
10-game hitting streak
inside out slang for trevor i love it
when he goes opposite field you know
that fastball he takes it off oh now he
can take a secondary pitch and drive it
later on in the game
story's in a really really good spot
right now
well it's now official the rockies have
three players riding at least a 10-game
hitting streak for the first time
to shatter back it's going to be a tough
chance for rojo he's not going to get it
so an infield hit for blackman
and now they're two aboard going out
two on no one out
and this ball's driven right center
field going back is brixton looking up
and it's off the very top of the wall
blackman following story home and he
will score standing up
cj crone again
i'd say he's locked in all three hits is
hitting opposite fields his chain jump
and cj smashes it into right center it's
high off the barrier
good read from charlie he knows it's not
going to be caught
brenton setting up getting his feet
ready
there's a chance he's going to sneak out
cj crone is now second in the national
league with rbi's at home
it's 43.
[Music]
crow gets a green light he's coming home
throw on its way
safe there safe at second 4-0
does a good job he shoots it opposite
field fastball away
aguilar doesn't get quite low enough
he's in the right spot but he just ends
up whiffing on it and de la cruz in
right this is the third throw he's
showing off his arm
the base is heavily populated with
rockies rogers at third story and second
crone at first
3-2 pitch
a big pitch for lazardo you go back to
change-up
ball four
diaz draws a walk
rodgers come on down
five-nothing
connor joe sack fly and an rbi single
and ripped to left field base hit story
will score trove coming home throw off
live
two more ribbies for connor joe
a career high four
well i love this approach billy he knows
that
pop's gonna try to get ahead
it's like a pitch hit at that wasn't it
it is
you come up there all the pressure's on
pop to
try to get ahead of you and as a as a
hitter
it's the easiest place to be in
another good night for the rockies
offense another good night for the rocky
starting pitcher gomber five shutout
innings and the rockies keep tacking on
swell got and missed and there's the hat
trick for anderson
it is strikeout number seven tonight for
austin gombert
one-two swung on it missed that's eight
strikeouts for gobber which matches his
career high
well he's using all of his pitches
that's the slider at the top of the
strike zone
he's locked in
after a tough performance 2-2
that is a trio of strikeouts in the
sixth inning austin gomber strikes out
the side a career high
nine punch outs for the left hander
and jackson lines the base hit left
field brinson held up for a second but
he is gonna come around third as joe
looked like he may have either slipped
or went down to slide to cut it off but
either way alex jackson has an rbi and
the marlins are on the board
and andy lips one down the right field
line long run blackman that'll fall in
fair
two runs are in for the marlins
the marlins try it out themselves
now going to right right off the end of
the bat
a lot of times you'll see
in coors field balls don't hook and
slice the same way they do at sea level
and alfaro out toward left center field
that is going to get down for a base hit
he's headed towards second he'll get
there
aguilar scores anderson to third and now
it's seven to four cut it off the end of
the bat just a little bit but plenty of
space in left center field
[Applause]
diaz flashes the multiple signs and
daniel
is
ready one-two pitch
and it's in the air to right charlie has
it and that's the ball game
the rockies make it two straight over
miami they're four and one on the home
stand a chance to make it 5-1 and sweep
the marlins tomorrow